les créateurs entreprise sont seuls en
général ils ne savent pas à qui
s'adresser ils commencent une activité
sans trop savoir où est-ce qu'ils sont
essentiellement sur le plan financier
ils connaissent assez bien le produit
mais l'accompagnement fait souvent
défaut dans ce domaine là le conseil
c'est que il faut s'adresser il faut
s'entourer de personnel compétent de
personnes compétent d'organismes
compétents par exemple vous avez à votre
disposition aujourd'hui des organismes
agréés des centres de gtion des
associations agréées qui peuvent
apporter un certain nombre de concours à
ces entreprises qui démarrent leur
activité les agap permettent au à ceux
qui adhèrent au agars de bénéficier d'un
certain nombre de d'avantages fiscaux
par exemple la non majoration des
résultats à sou mettre à l'impôt le fait
également que ces organismes agré
peuvent leur apporter un concours en
matière de formation une meilleure
connaissance de la compabilité et une
meilleure connaissance dans la gestion
de leur affaires la gestion est capital
et sans gestion on ne peut pas aller
très loin parce qu'on a' pas d'objectif
on n' pas une visibilité de son avenir
immédiat